ASSEMBLY MEMBER DALY NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM THE
SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL PREPARE
THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN THE
ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL. HURRY
ARAMBULA. BAUER-KAHAN BERMAN.
BIGELOW BLOOM. BOERNER HORVATH
BONTA. BRO BURKE CALDERON
CARRILLO CERVANTES CHAU CHEN
DAVID CHIU CHOI KANSEN CHU
COOLEY COOPER CUNNINGHAM DALY
DALY DEEP. EGGMAN FLORA FONG
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA GIPSON GLORIA
GONZALEZ IS GRAY GRAYSON HOLDEN
IRWIN JONES SAWYER KALRA
KAMLAGER KILEY LACKEY LEVINE
LIMON LOW MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS
MAYES MCCARTY MEDINA MELENDEZ
MULLIN MURATSUCHI NAZARIAN
OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL PATTERSON
PETRIE-NORRIS QUIRK QUIRK SILVA.
RAMOS RADIUS THREE OF US ROBERT
RIVAS RODRIGUEZ RUBIO SALAS
SANTIAGO SMITH STONE TING
VOEPEL WALDRON WEBER WICKS WOOD
MISTER SPEAKER.
NUMBER IS A
QUORUM IS PRESENT. A QUORUM IS
PRESENT IN THE ASSEMBLY. WE ASK
OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS IN THE
REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND IN THE
GALLERY. TO PLEASE STAND FOR
THE PRAYER. TODAY'S PRAYER WILL
BE OFFERED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER DOCTOR WEBER. THAT IS FOR.
YOUR FATHER MARCH IS WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH AND WE WILL HAVE
A UNIQUE HONOR OF MEETING AND
CELEBRATING ONE HUNDRED AND
TWENTY POWERFUL WOMEN. WOMEN
WHO WILL BE CALL SUCCESSFUL
RESILIENT STRONG PERSEVERING
AND EVEN THOSE WHO HOLD UP THE
SKY. THIS MONTH WILL MAKERS
MINDFUL OF ALL OF THE
SCRIPTURES THAT WE'VE HEARD
LIKE PROVERBS THIRTY ONE TALKS
ABOUT THE VIRTUOUS WOMAN BEING
MORE PRECIOUS THAN RUBIES ARE
THE PORTRAIT THE CALLS WOMEN
PHENOMENAL AND HOTELS BUT
THEY'RE TOLD A CYPRESS IN
STRONG BEYOND DEFINITION. AND
WE WILL LEARN THE IMPORTANCE TO
THE ROLE OF WOMEN IN THIS SKIN
CALIFORNIA AND THIS NATION YES
THIS IS THE MARK OF WOMEN
CELEBRATION. HOWEVER IN THE
MIDST OF OUR CELEBRATION LET US
NOT FORGET THOSE WHO DESPITE
THEIR STRONGEST EFFORTS. ARE
STILL OPPRESSED. LET US
REMEMBER EVEN OUR PEERS AND
PLAY MATES. WHO WHO BASICALLY
PARTICIPATED IN THE SAME THINGS
WE DID. BUT HAVE NOT SHARED IN
THE SUCCESS AND PROSPERITY BUT
WE HAVE. IN OUR CELEBRATION LET
US TAKE TIME TO CONTEMPLATE THE
LARGE NUMBER OF WOMEN SLEEPING
ON OUR STREETS WITH THEIR
CHILDREN. THAT IS NOT FORGET
THAT 40% OF THE HOMELESS WOMEN
IN LOS ANGELES ARE BLACK WOMEN
AND THEIR CHILDREN. LET US
REMEMBER THAT AS WE FIGHT TO
REDUCE THE PRISON POPULATION IN
THE STATION. THE POPULATION OF
WOMEN IN PRISON A IT IS
INCREASING. THIS TRYING TO
WHERE WE HAVE BEEN HAVE BEEN
PAID WITH HARD WORK AND
STRUGGLE AND IT IS PAID OFF FOR
MANY OF US. HOWEVER THERE ARE
STILL THOSE WHOSE HARD WORK AND
STRUGGLE HAS NOT MET AT THE
SAME RESULTS. FOR EVER LET US
KEEP WAS GRATEFUL SO THAT WE
WITH WHEN WE TAKE THE OATH OF
FREDERICK DOUGLASS WAS ONCE A
FORMER SLAVE. AND ENJOY THE
PLEASURES THAT OTHERS NEVER DID
BUT HE NEVER FORGOT FROM QUINCY
COME. MAY WE ALSO SAY AS HE DID
THAT IMPROPER GET THESE
CHILDREN THESE BLEEDING
CHILDREN OF SORROW. IN MAY MY
RIGHT HAND FORGET ITS CUTTING
IN MAY MY TONGUE PLEA FOR THE
ROOF OF MY MOUTH. THESE THE ALL
BLESSINGS WE THINK IN YOUR NAME
A MAN. THANK YOU DOCTOR WEBER
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING AND JOIN
US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE PLEASE
JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER BONTA AS
HE LEADS US IN THE PLEDGE
MISTER WHAT. THANK YOU I PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG. A AND-
OKAY ASIAN. ISRAEL S. R. THANK
YOU MAY BE SEATED. READING OF
THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
WEDNESDAY FEBRUARY TWENTY SIX
TWENTY TWENTY THE SALLY MET AT
SEVEN AM CALDERON MOVES AND MR
FLORA SECONDS THAT THE READING
OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S JOURNAL
BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS
THERE ARE NONE. INTRODUCTION
REFERENCE TO BILLS WILL BE
DEFERRED REPORTS OF COMMITTEES
WILL BE DEEMED READ AND
AMENDMENTS DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES FROM
THE SENATE THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THE ABSENCES TODAY
FOR PERSONAL BUSINESS ASSEMBLY
MEMBERS GLORIA. HOLDEN SMITH
AMP FONG AND FOR ILLNESS
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS FRAZIER
GABRIEL QUIRK SILVA AND QUIRK.
M. FOR MATERNITY LEAVE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CERVANTES MR BONTA YOU
ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
PROCEDURAL MOTIONS I'M SORRY
MISTER CALDERON. I HAD MEASURE
BONTA ON MY MIND MISTER
CALDERON YOU ARE RECOGNIZED YOU
MISTER SPEAKER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE ANYTHING A TO
ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS TO
DOLLY AND A DONNA O'DONNELL TO
HAVE GUESTS AND PHOTOGRAPHERS
ON THE FLOOR ASSEMBLYMEMBER
DOLLARS GAS WILL BE SEATED AT
HER DESK WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH
SHALL BE THE ORDER I REQUEST
UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO SUSPEND
ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE POINT
FIVE TO ALLOW SOMETHING MEMBERS
COOLEY WALDRON GALLAGHER TO
SPEAK. AS WELL AS DOCTOR WEBER
TO SPEAK ON A GERMAN MEMBER
TODAY AGAIN WITHOUT OBJECTION
SUCH SHALL BE THE ORDER AT THE
REQUEST OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN I'M GIVING A ONE AND DAY
NOTICE TO REMOVE I TO ME TWENTY
YES SB FIVE EIGHTY EIGHT. ARE
TO LETTER FROM THE INACTIVE
FILE. THE CLERK WILL NOTE.
PURSUANTTO ASSEMBLY RULE
NINETY SIX I REQUEST UNANIMOUS
CONSENT TO RE REFER SB THREE
TWELVE LEYVA FROM THE VETERANS
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE TO THE RULES
COMMITTEE. AGAIN WITHOUT
OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE THE
ORDER. MEMBERS WE HAVE A NUMBER
OF GUEST WITH US IN THE CHAMBER
TODAY. I'M GOING TO RECOGNIZE
MISTER KANSEN CHU. IN THE REAR
OF THE CHAMBER AT MY DESK.
MISTER KANSEN CHU. YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FROM MY DESK. THANK
YOU VERY MUCH I MISTER SPEAKER
SAYING CALLING. I RISE TODAY TO
INTRODUCE CALIFORNIA'S I. F.
DIVISION FIVE A. STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP. HE DOES HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL TEAM FROM
IMPEDE US THE UNDEAD TO TWENTY
FIRST ASSEMBLY DISTRICT. ON
DECEMBER FURTEENS A TWENTY
NINETEEN MILPITAS HIGH SCHOOL
TROJANS WON THE CIF DIVISION
FIVE A. STATE CHAMPIONSHIP BY
DEFEATING RESITA HIGH SCHOOL BY
THE SCORE OF THIRTY FOUR TWO
ZERO. THIS IS THEIR SECOND
STATE. SECOND AT THE STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP IN THE LAST THREE
YEARS I'M PROUD TO SAY THAT THE
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT TWENTY FIVE
HAS PRODUCED THE STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP FOR THE LAST THREE
YEARS IN THE ROLE ENDED
MILPITAS HIGH SCHOOL TROJANS
HAS WON TWO OF THEM IN TWENTY
SEVENTEEN AND TWENTY NINETEEN.
ALTHOUGH THE TEAM STARTED THE
SEASON WAS ONE TWO SIX RECORD.
THEY FINALIZED DATE DIFFERENT
IS STRONG AND WON THE
CHAMPIONSHIP. THE STATE
CHAMPIONSHIP VICTORY WAS THIRD
RESULT OF MANY YEARS OF MANY
HOURS OF TRAINING DETERMINATION
AND TEAM WORK BY ALL THE
PLAYERS AND COACHES. ALSO I
WOULD LIKE TO RECOGNIZE TO
PARENTS AND FAMILIES OF THE
PLAYERS AND COACHES WHO
CONTINUE TO SUPPORT THEM. THE
THEIR FOOTBALL TEAM BROUGHT
TOGETHER OUR COMMUNITY IN CHEER
FOR THEIR SUCCESS WHEN YOU WERE
DOWN AND IN THE END CELEBRATE
WAS SEPARATE AND I WAS VERY
HONORED TO JOIN THEM- FOR THE
WONDERFUL CELEBRATION AND MOVE
HE DOES HIGH SCHOOL.
CONGRATULATIONS TO HELP COACH
CALLIE KING AND HIS PAYING ON
WINNING THEIR SECOND STATE HI.
I'D LIKE TO ESPECIALLY TO
CONGRATULATE THE SENIORS- ON
THE FOOTBALL TEAM OR MOST-
THEY'RE ALL STANDING UP ON THE-
OF GALLERY THERE. LIKE TO
REALLY COME GRADUALLY THE
SENIOR SOUNDER TEAM FOR THE
ERROR TREMENDOUS ACHIEVEMENT
THIS YEAR AND COMPETING YOUR
FOUR YEARS OF HIGH SCHOOL IN
THE STATE CHAMPIONSHIP. WE
ISSUE THE QUAKE THE FASTEN YOUR
FUTURE ENDEAVOR TO ALL THE
STUDENTS RETURNING NEXT YEAR.
HAVE A GREAT SCHOOL YEAR ON AND
OFF THE FIELD. AND WE ALL WISH
TO CELEBRATE THIS AGAIN NEXT
YEAR. TODAY ON THE FLOOR I'M
PROUD TO WELCOME REPEAT AS HIGH
SCHOOL FOOTBALL COACH KELLY
CAME. RIGHT BEHIND ME ALL RIGHT
AND ALSO WE JOINED A COACH
CALLIE WE HAVE THE ATHLETIC
DIRECTOR JOIN A BUTCHER. ZIPPO
FRANCIS ROLE HOPS NICK YOU AND
TING CAPTAIN WE'RE TREATING
CAPTAIN HERE AND HAD TO READ.
JOB NUMBER THERE'S ME ARMOR
SORRY ABOUT THAT AND THE ALSO
THE A LOT. AND THE- WHOLE HOST
WAIT. POROUS AND THE JOE WE-
RESERVE. AND ALSO OUR SUPREME
AS- YOUR- FROM THE IMPACT THE
BILL PETER HYPED AS UNIFIED
DISTRICT HONG LEARNED THAT MOVE
DOES BOARD. PRESS NOR WOULD
MOVIE THIS THE SCHOOL BOARD
VICE PRESIDENT AND ALL WE'RE
PLEASED TO TOLD OVERCOME. JOIN
ME WHAT THE OF MILL PIZZAS MORE
MEMBERS AND BOTH PRESS KELLY IT
AND THE REST ALL THE TEAM AND
AS COACH UP IN THE GALLERY. SO
CALLING PLEASE JOIN ME TO COME.
AND GIVEN A WARM. STATE
ASSEMBLY WELL COME TO THE C. I.
L. FIVE EIGHT CHAMPIONSHIP. HE
DOES HIGH SCHOOL TROJANS.
MEMBERS WE HAVE ADDITIONAL
GUEST WITH US TODAY. MS DALLY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
SPECIAL GUESTS INTRODUCTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO WELCOME
CAP CALIFORNIA POLYTECHNIC
STATE UNIVERSITY CAL POLICY
UNLESS BEST THOUGH TO THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY. I AM
JOINED ON THE FLOOR ASSEMBLY
FOR BIKE HOW PLACE PRESIDENT
JEFF ARMSTRONG INTO STUDENTS
MASON PRY PULL A SIT A CIVIL
ENGINEERING MAJOR FROM ELK
GROVE AND TINA TRUE HONG OF.
FOOD SCIENCE MAJOR FROM. BILL
PDS STANDING ASSEMBLY GALLERY
OR MRS SHARON ARMSTRONG AND
FOURTEEN ADDITIONAL STUDENTS.
COWBOYS LOCATION IN SAN LUIS
OBISPO GIVE STUDENTS ACCESS TO
OPPORTUNITIES FOR HANDS ON
RESEARCH IN AGRICULTURE WINE
MAKING AND DISTINCTIVE CULTURAL
ECO SYSTEMS AS WELL AS TACK I
AM A PROUD PARENTS OF A CURRENT
SOPHOMORE AT CAL POLY WHO IS
CITY AGRICULTURAL SCIENCE. AS
WELL SOON TO BE A SECOND.
STUDENT THERE IN THIS FALL. THE
STUDENTS PRESS PRESENTS ARE
AMONG THE BEST AND THE
BRIGHTEST I CAL POLLY AND
REPRESENT EACH THE SIX CAL POLY
COLLEGES. ALL HAVE RECEIVED
SPECIAL RECOGNITION IN THEIR
ACADEMIC DISCIPLINES FOR
EXAMPLE MASON AND HIS TEAM WON
SECOND PLACE OVERALL AND FIRST
PLACE FINAL PRODUCT IN THE TWO
THOUSAND NINETEEN AMERICAN
NATIONAL CONCRETE CANOE
COMPETITION. TINA AND HER TEAM
WON THIRD PLACE GRAND CUDA AND
FIFTH PLACE SMOKED GOUDA AT THE
TWENTIETH BIENNIAL YOU SEE.
CHAMPIONSHIP CHEESE CONTEST I'D
LIKE TO THINK JEFF ARMSTRONG
HIS ADMINISTRATION AND FACULTY
OF THE CAL POLY FOR EDUCATING
SUCH AN AMAZING GROUP OF
STUDENTS MANY OF WHOM WILL GO
ON TO SECURE EMPLOYMENT IN
HIGHLY SKILLED INDUSTRIES.
IMPORTANT TORRENT THE
CALIFORNIA ECONOMY I ASKED MY
CALL THE COLLEAGUES PLEASE GIVE
THEM A ROUND OF APPLAUSE IN
APPRECIATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
THE STUDENTS.
AND IS
BOERNER HORVATH YOUR AGAIN
RECORD I'M SORRY MISS. DALLY
YOUR RECORD. SO I JUST WENT OUT
TO ALSO INTRODUCE OUR DAUGHTER
ROSLIN IS ON THE FLOOR HERE
WITH ME TODAY SHE IS IN THE
FIFTH GRADE AND HAS STARTED
SCHOOL HERE IN SACRAMENTO AND
IS TRANSITIONING VERY WELL SO
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND- PLEASE
WELCOME HER.
AND NOW MISS
BOERNER HORVATH YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GUESTS AND
PRODUCTION. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
MISTER SPEAKER I WANT TO
WELCOME THE FIFTH GRADE
CLASSROOM ACOSTA HEIGHTS
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL. HE WAS UP
THERE IF YOU WANT TO STAND UP.
WELCOME THEM THEY TOOK A FLIGHT
EARLY THIS MORNING THE FLIGHT
WAS DELAYED AND THEY NEEDED
HERE. SO PLEASE WELCOME THEM
THEY'RE WORKING ON REALLY
LOOKING AT CALIFORNIA POLITICS
THERE FOLLOWING ACTIVE
LEGISLATION. SO THEY COME AT
YOUR OFFICES PLEASE GIVE THEM
THE TIME TO LISTEN TO THEIR
IMPORTANT ISSUES. IT'S AN
SOMEONE COURAGE THAT THESE
BRIGHT KIDS. COMING UP HERE TO
BE PART OF OUR LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. AND THE ACTIVE
ENGAGED. IN OUR DEMOCRACY.
THANK YOU TO THE TEACHERS AND-
WELL TODAY IF POSSIBLE IT'S
VERY AND THEN MY FIRST ENTIRE.
CAN UP FROM I GUESS LET'S THEM
A MORE WELCOME. THEY YOU FOR.
MEMBERS WE ARE MOVING TO
BUSINESS ON THE DAILY FILE. ON
RECONSIDERATION FILE ITEMS ONE
TWO AND THREE ARE TO BE
CONTINUED. ON THE ASSEMBLY
READING FILE. FILE ITEM FOR
PASS AND RETAIN. THAT BRINGS US
TO. FILE ITEM NUMBER FIVE. IT'S
ACR ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY MS
RUBIO. CLOCK RATE ASSEMBLY-
RESOLUTION ONE SEVENTY EIGHT BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLANCA RUBIO
BELT TO SCHOOL BREAKFAST WEEK
IS RUBIO. THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER. AND MEMBERS COLLEAGUES
I RISE TO RE YOUR SUPPORT ON
ACR ONE SEVENTY EIGHT TO
DECLARE SO THROUGH THE SIX
SCHOOL BREAKFAST WEEK CAL. AS A
FORMER TEACHER I SAW MANY
STUDENTS COME TO THE SCHOOL ON
AN EMPTY STOMACH EMPTY STOMACH.
WHICH THEN AFFECTED THEIR
ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE THIS
RESOLUTION HIGHLIGHTS HOW
SCHOOL BREAKFAST IS A VALUABLE
TOOL IN FIGHTING CHILD HUNGER
AND SUPPORTING THE ACADEMIC
SUCCESS A BIT OF A VULNERABLE
CALIFORNIA POPULATION. SCHOOL
BREAKFAST IS AN INVESTMENT IN
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE AND OUR
CHILDREN. WHEN STUDENTS START
THEIR DAY WITH A HEALTHY
BREAKFAST PRINCIPALS AND
TEACHERS REPORT THAT THEY
ATTEND AN AVERAGE OF ONE POINT
FIVE MORE DAYS OF SCHOOL PER
YEAR. SCORE HIGHER ON TESTS AND
ARE 20% MORE LIKELY TO GRADUATE
HIGH SCHOOL. IN FACT A RECENT
REPORT SHOWED THAT OFFERING
BREAKFAST AS PART OF THE SCHOOL
DAY CAN SIGNIFICANTLY REDUCE
CHRONIC ABSENTEEISM. A FORMER
SCHOOL BOARD MEMBER I WANT TO
COMMEND ALL THOSE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS IN MY REGION THAT
HAVE BEEN PARTICIPATING IN THIS
CRITICAL PROGRAM THAT PROVIDES
MEALS FOR OUR CHILDREN. THE
ADMINISTRATORS AND STRUCTURES
OF THAT SAN GABRIEL VALLEY ARE
LEADING BY EXAMPLE IN THEIR
EFFORTS TO PROVIDE STUDENTS
WITH EVERY CHANCE TO SUCCEED. I
HOPE THAT WITH THIS RESOLUTION
WE CONTINUE TO RAISE AWARENESS
OF SCHOOL BREAKFAST PROGRAMS
AND TAKE GREATER ADVANTAGE OF
THE OPPORTUNITY THEY OFFERED TO
HELP OUR CHILDREN THRIVE.
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE ON ACR ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT. THANK YOU MS
RUBIO MR BLOOM WE ARE
RECOGNIZED THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RISE IN SUPPORT OF
ACR ONE SEVENTY EIGHT I WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN
PARK FOR BRINGING THE
RESOLUTION FORWARD. SCHOOL
BREAKFAST PROGRAMS ARE CRITICAL
ARE CRITICAL FOR CHILDREN'S
NUTRITION. FIFTY YEARS AGO
OBESITY WAS A RELATIVELY RARE
CONDITION BUT TODAY ONE THIRD
OF CHILDREN AGED TEN TO
SEVENTEEN ARE OBESE AND IF
NOTHING CHANGES. HALF OF
AMERICA HALF OF AMERICA WILL BE
OBESE WITHIN APPROXIMATELY TEN
YEARS. AND WITH THOSE NUMBERS
COME INCREASES IN DIABETES
HEART DISEASE FATTY LIVER
DISEASE AND MANY OTHER
CONSEQUENCES. AFRICAN AMERICANS
AND LATINOS STATISTICS ARE EVEN
HIGHER. ASIDE FROM THE NEGATIVE
HEALTH EFFECTS FISCAL COSTS ARE
EXTREME. IF ADULT BODY MASS
INDEX FELL BY ONLY 5%
CALIFORNIA COULD SAVE EIGHTY
TWO POINT SEVEN BILLION DOLLARS
IN OBESITY RELATED HEALTH COSTS
BY TWENTY THIRTY. FOR THE
HEALTH OF OUR CHILDREN
THROUGHOUT THEIR LIVES WE NEED
TO ENACT POLICIES THAT DRIVE
CHANGES IN BEHAVIOR AND
NUTRITION PROGRAMS LIKE SCHOOL
BREAKFAST AFTER A LIKE AFTER
SCHOOL BREAKFAST PROGRAMS LIKE
AFTER THE BELL. CAN HELP REDUCE
CONSUMPTION OF SUGARY BEVERAGES
AND INCREASED CONSUMPTION OF
HEALTHY WHOLE GRAIN PRODUCTS
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES THAT ALL
HAVE BEEN SHOWN TO REDUCE THE
OBESITY RATE IN CHILDREN. THESE
ARE THE KIND OF EFFORTS THAT
FIRST LADY MICHELLE OBAMA HAS
CHAMPIONED BUT UNFORTUNATELY
HER PROGRAMS ARE BEING ROLLED
BACK BY THE BY OUR CURRENT
AGRICULTURE CELL. AGRICULTURE
SECRETARY SONNY PERDUE AND THE
TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
RESOLUTIONS LIKE ACR ONE
SEVENTY EIGHT CHAMPIONING THE
IMPORTANCE OF SCHOOL BREAKFASTS
HELP US TO UNDERSTAND AND
FURTHER POLICIES THAT WILL
REDUCE THE EPIDEMIC OF OBESITY
THAT IS PLAGUING OUR COUNTRY.
AND THAT IS WHY I URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE. SURE KANSEN CHU YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED. CHECK YOUR MISTER
SPEAKER SANG COLLEAGUES ARE
RISING STRONG SUPPORTER OF ACR
ONE SEVENTY EIGHT AND WANT TO
THANK MY COLLEAGUE FROM BALDWIN
PARK FOR BRINGING THIS MEASURE
FOR US OF ALMOST GLOBAL MEMBERS
I HAVE EXPERIENCE IT FIRSTHAND
THAT TOO MANY KIDS BECAUSE THEY
COME TO SCHOOL HUNGRY WITHOUT
EATING BREAKFAST WE KNOW THIS
IN FACT THEIR ABILITY TO LEARN.
TO BE ATTENTIVE IN THE CLASS
AND ACADEMIC PERFORMANCE AND
OVER ALL HELL'S WE KNOW THAT
NOT EVEN HALF OF TO STUDENTS
WHO ARE ILLEGIBLE FOR FREE OR
REDUCED PRICE SCHOOL MALES
PARTICIPATE IN THE SCHOOL
BREAKFAST WE MUST DO EVERYTHING
WE CAN IN OUR POWER TO INCREASE
THE PARTICIPATION IN THOSE
PROGRAM TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
CHILDREN TO SIT IN THE
CLASSROOM. HUNGRY LOOK LOOKING
AT THE LARGER PICTURE OF THE
ACHIEVEMENT GAP WE MUST INCLUDE
THIS IN OUR COME CONVERSATION.
KIDS CANNOT REACH THEIR
POTENTIAL AND EXCEL WITHOUT THE
NUTRITION THEY NEED I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR I
WILL. THANK YOU MISTER TO.
SEEING NO OTHER MEMBERS SEE
RECOGNITION AND MS RUBIO YOU
MAY CLOSE IF YOU WISH AND WOULD
YOU LIKE CO AUTHORS ON THE
STAGE YES THANK YOU MISTER
SPEAKER I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE AND ASK THAT THE
REAL BE OPEN FOR- COOPER'S.
THANK YOU MS RUBIO MEMBERS
MISTER BSS IN THE FIRST ROLL ON
THE RESOLUTION WE OFFER CO
AUTHORS CLERK WILL OPEN THE
ROLE. MEMBERS THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS ON THE RESOLUTION. THIS
IS FOR CO AUTHORS. AS FOR CO
IS FOR CO AUTHORS.
CLARK WELL
CLOSE RATHER SIXTY ONE CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED.
MOVIE TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX
THIS IS. H. R. EIGHTY FOUR
CORKERY HOUSE RESOLUTION EIGHTY
FOUR BY FAMILY MEMBER O'DONNELL
RELATIVE TO READ ACROSS AMERICA
DAY MISTER O'DONNELL ON THE
RESOLUTION. MISTER SPEAKER AND
MEMBERS I AM PLEASED TO PRESENT
HR EIGHTY FOUR WHICH WILL
DESIGNATE TODAY MARCH SECOND
TWENTY TWENTY AS READ ACROSS
AMERICA DAY. READ ACROSS
AMERICA IS AN ANNUAL READING
MOTIVATION AND AWARENESS
PROGRAM THAT CALLS FOR EVERY
CHILD IN EVERY COMMUNITY TO
CELEBRATE READING ON MARCH
SECOND. THE BIRTHDAY OF THE
BELOVED CHILDREN'S AUTHOR DR
SEUSS MOTIVATING CHILDREN IS
IMPORTANT MOTIVATING CHILDREN
TO READ IS IMPORTANT FOR
STUDENT ACHIEVEMENT AND FOR
CREATING LIFELONG READERS AND
ALSO LIFELONG EARNERS. STUDIES
HAVE SHOWN THAT STUDENTS WHO DO
WHO DO MORE READING AT HOME ARE
BETTER READERS THROUGHOUT THEIR
LIVES OF COURSE. PLEASE JOIN ME
IN RECOGNIZING MARCH SECOND AS
READ ACROSS AMERICA DAY TO HELP
FOSTER A LOVE OF READING IN
CALIFORNIA SCHOOLS. AND I ASKED
THAT THE FIRST WILL BE OPEN FOR
CO AUTHORS AND ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU MISTER
O'DONNELL. SEE NO DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE RESOLUTION MR
O'DONNELL'S ASKING THAT THE
FIRST ROLE THE OPEN FOR CO
AUTHORS. CLICK LIBERAL MEMBERS
THIS IS FOR CO AUTHORS THIS IS
FOR CO AUTHORS ON THE
RESOLUTION. THIS IS FOR CO
AUTHORS. THE CLARK WELL. CLOSER
ALL THEIR SIXTY SEVEN CO
AUTHORS ADDED AND WITHOUT
OBJECTION WE MAY TAKE A VOICE
VOTE ON THE RESOLUTION ALL
THOSE IN FAVOR SAY AYE AYE
OPPOSED SAY NAY. THE AYES HAVE
IT THE RESOLUTION IS ADOPTED
MEMBERS. MEMBERS PLEASE KEEP
THE VOLUME LEVEL IN THE CHAMBER
MANAGEABLE MISTER O'DONNELL YOU
HAVE GUESTS WITH US RELATIVE TO
THE RESOLUTION. ARE YOU MISTER
SPEAKER PLEASE HELP ME WELCOME
SHELLEY GOTTEN A FIFTH GRADE
TEACHER IN THE ELK GROVE
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT AND THE
CALIFORNIA TEACHERS ASSOCIATION
BOARD MEMBER. SHE IS JOINED US
TODAY AS PART OF OUR ANNUAL
READ ACROSS AMERICA DAY
CELEBRATION IF YOU CAN READ
THANKA TEACHER AND LET'S
WELCOME IT'S GOTTEN.
MEMBERS
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE BRIEFLY
BACK TO GAS INTRODUCTIONS MS
AGUILAR CURRY I BELIEVE YOUR
GUESTS HAVE ARRIVED IN THE
CHAMBER TODAY MISS AGUIAR-CURRY
YOU ARE RECOGNIZED. THANK YOU
MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS I
RISE TODAY TO WELCOME GUESTS
WHO ARE HERE IN THE GALLERY TO
RECOGNIZE WOMEN IN CONSTRUCTION
WEEK WHICH IS MARCH FIRST TO
THE SEVENTH PLEASE STAND GALS.
WE HAVE REPRESENTATIVES FROM
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL BILL
EXCHANGE. CALIFORNIA BUILDING
INDUSTRY ASSOCIATION
PROFESSIONAL WOMEN IN BUILDING
ASSOCIATED BUILDERS AND
CONTRACTORS NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AND THE STATE BUILDING AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL.
ACR ONE SIXTY NINE IS ON
CONSENT TODAY THIS RESOLUTION
RECOGNIZES THE ADVANCEMENT OF
WOMEN WHO ARE BUILDING CAREERS
IN THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY
AND HIGHLIGHTS ARE EFFORTS TO
ADDRESS CALIFORNIA'S
INFRASTRUCTURE IN HOUSING
NEEDS. ALTHOUGH WOMEN FACE
UNDER MISS UNDER REPRESENTATION
IN THE CNSTRUCTION FIELD TODAY
THEY ARE N UNTAPPED RESOURCE
TO HELP CLOSE THE INDUSTRY
SKILLED WORKING IN LABOR GROUP.
LET'S GIVE THEM A WARM ASSEMBLY
WELCOME AND CELEBRATION OF THE
INVALUABLE CONTRIBUTIONS OF
WOMEN TO CALIFORNIA'S.
THANK
YOU MEMBERS BACK ON THE FILE
SENATE THIRD READING FILE ITEM
NUMBER SEVEN PASS AND RETAIN.
MEMBERS A COUPLE OF
ANNOUNCEMENTS. TODAY IS THE
FILING DEADLINE FOR MEMBERS. TO
FILE THEIR FORM SEVEN HUNDRED
WITH THE F. P. PC. PLEASE BE
MINDFUL OF THAT DEADLINE. AND
MEMBERS. ON YOUR DESKS YOU WILL
FIND THIS YEAR'S WOMEN'S
HISTORY MONTH CALENDAR.
PROVIDED BY THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE WOMEN'S CAUCUS VICE
CHAIR ASSEMBLY MEMBER ON THE
MOUND. ADDITIONAL CALENDARS ARE
AVAILABLE TO ORDER THROUGH
REPROGRAPHICS THANK YOU
ASSEMBLY WOMAN AMOUNT AND THE
WOMEN'S CAUCUS. SESSION
SCHEDULE IS AS FOLLOWS. TUESDAY
MARCH THIRD NO FLOOR SESSION NO
CHECK IN SESSION WEDNESDAY
MARCH THE FOURTH CHECK IN
SESSION THURSDAY MARCH THE
FIFTH FLOOR SESSION IS AT NINE
AM. IN THE ABSENCE OF OBJECTION
THE QUORUM CALL IS LIFTED. AND
WE WILL NOW MOVE THE PREVIOUSLY
ANNOUNCED THE GERMANS IN MEMORY.
AND MEMBERS I WOULD ASK THAT
YOU PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS OR
TAKE YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF
THE FLOOR. AT THIS TIME.
MEMBERS WE ARE THE GERMANS
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS. OR TAKE
YOUR CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE
FLOOR. THE FOLLOWING MEMBERS
WERE GRANTED PRIOR PERMISSION
IS PERMISSION TO SPEAK ON A
GERMAN IN MEMORY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER COOLEY YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY.
COLLEAGUES I RISE TODAY TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF A GOOD
FRIEND. AND A GREAT PART OF
THIS INSTITUTION. DOUGLAS DOUG
HOLLAND. DOUG WAS A PUBLIC
SERVANT HERE SIR WITH US FOR
TWENTY YEARS TWENTY SEVEN YEARS
HERE IN THE ASSEMBLY. HE AND I
HAD A VERY CLOSE RELATIONSHIP
WHERE ACTIONS SAY GOOD FRIENDS.
THOUGH IN HIS DEVOTION TO
PUBLIC SERVICE HE AND I WERE
OPPONENTS IN TWENTY FOURTEEN IN
A DECEMBER DISTRICT FOR A FINE
MAN WAS DUG TALENT. AND SORTS
WITH GREAT REGRET THAT I
RECOUNT THAT ON JANUARY TWENTY
THIRD OF THIS YEAR. MY FRIEND
DOUG GALLON THIS PARTNER IN OUR
LAW MAKING HERE IS TAKE APPLE
FOR MORE THAN A QUARTER
CENTURY. PASSED AWAY AFTER A
BRIEF BUT DIGNIFIED BATTLE WITH
RENAL CELL CARCINOMA. DOUG WAS
BORN MAY THIRD NINETEEN FIFTY
TWO SO HE WAS ON THE SCENE A
LITTLE BIT EARLIER THAN ME NOT
MUCH IN DETROIT MICHIGAN. GREW
UP LIVING ON HIS FAMILY FARM IN
HENNING MINNESOTA. AND I AM
HAVING ACTUALLY EVER DISCLOSES
TO ANYONE CERTAINLY NOT HERE'S
FROM NOT THE FAMILY. BUT
HITTING. ISM IS A FAMILY NAME
IN MY FAMILY. MY GRANDFATHER
WAS FROM A WISCONSIN NEXT DOOR
TO MINNESOTA. AND SO
INTERESTING TO ME THAT MY
FRIEND DOG ACTUALLY GREW UP IN
HìNH IN MINNESOTA. HE WAS PART
OF THAT HIGH SCHOOL WAS A
MEMBER THE MINNESOTA ALL STATE
CHOIR CHOIR HAD A TREMENDOUS
VOICE DID A LOT OF RADIO FOR
HIS CAUCUS MEMBERS- GREAT TENER.
AND AFTER YOU GRADUATE FROM HIM
IN HIGH SCHOOL AND I PLAN TO
RETURN THIS IN A MINUTE. HE
ACTUALLY ENTER THE UNITED
STATES ARMED SERVICES UNITED
STATES AIRFORCE. HE SERVED IN
UPPER PENINSULA MICHIGAN HE WAS
A RADAR OPERATOR PART OF THE
NORAD SYSTEM. SO HE WAS A PART
OF THE ROLE IN THE AIR FORCE
ARE REALLY LOOKING FOR TROUBLE
FROM AFAR OFF. AND TAKE A
PREEMPTIVE STEPS. WHICH A AS I
LOOK AT MY COLLEAGUES ON THE
FOR THAT KIND OF HAS THE PERILS
TO THE PUBLIC SERVICE HERE IN
THE CAPITAL ACTUALLY. AFTER
DISCHARGE HE WENT ON TO SERVE-
IN MICHIGAN PARTNER CORRECTIONS
WALL GOING TO NORTHERN MICHIGAN
UNIVERSITY. HE EVENTUALLY CAME
TO CALIFORNIA IN HIS MID
TWENTIES HE ESTABLISHED A
PRIVATE SECTOR FIRM. SECURITY
FIRM SERVICES FOR BAY AREA- AND
THEN HEARING. OPPORTUNITY FOR
PUBLIC SERVICE THE LEGISLATURE
THAT'S WHAT HE BEGAN TO DO. AND
HE BECAME AN EXPERT IN THE
FIELD OF AGRICULTURE WATER
POLICY NATURAL RESOURCES AND
HEARING HIS TIME IN THE
ASSEMBLY AND A LITTLE BIT IN
THE SENATE HE WORE MANY HATS.
AND THAT IS SORT THE WAY OUR
CAREERS GO. FIRST TIMES DOG WAS
ALLEGE SAVE EIGHT A FIELD
REPRESENTATIVE A LEGISLATIVE
DIRECTOR. A COMMITTEE CONSULT.
CHIEF OF STAFF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PHIL WYMAN. AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER
SHIRLEY HORTON AND THEN THE
DIRECTOR OF MEMBER SERVICES FOR
THE ENTIRE SOME REPUBLICAN
CAUCUS. SHE JUST SEE A SEASONED
INDIVIDUAL WHO WENT TO THE
INSTITUTION LEARNED A LOT OF
JOBS AND KEPT GIVING. ARM HE
HAD A CHANCE TO SHAPE PUBLIC
POLICY IN A VERY PERSONAL WAY.
WHEN HE AND HIS FAMILY LOST A
GRANDSON DUSTIN. TO CHILD ABUSE
IN NINETEEN NINETY EIGHT. AND
HE HAD A HAND IN RALLY IN
SUPPORT FOR LAW DUSTIN'S LAW.
WHICH WOULD PROTECT CHILDREN
INSURER THAT FAMILIES WERE
FORMED IF A ABUSER RETURN FROM
PRISON. AND THE THAT LAW DUSTIN
LAW WHICH DESIGNED TO DEAL WITH
THAT FACT PATTERN IT'S SO HE
WAS ABLE TO KIND OF TAKE SOME
OF THE PAIN IN HIS FAMILY AND
CONVERTED TO A POSITIVE GOOD.
DOUG WAS PROMINENT FIGURE IN
THE COMMUNITY ROSEMONT- HE WAS
A PESIDENT ROSE ROCKNE SO
SHE'S FRACTURED NUMBER YEARS
ALSO ACT WITH THE ROSE ONE
ROTARY CLUB OR THE CARMICHAEL
ROTARY CLUB. AND THIS IS SORT
OF WHERE I BRING BACK IN THAT
MILITARY SERVICE AS I LOOK AT
FAMILY. ARE YEAH HE WAS OF
HONORED VERY NICE STATES
AIRFORCE. THE NEXT YEAR TICKET
IS A FORMAL VALUE WHEN HE WAS
THERE IN THE SEVENTIES BUT BY
THE NINETIES IN THE U. S. AIR
FORCE THEY HAD UNDERSTOOD
ARTICULATE THAT ONE OF THEIR
COMMON VALUES. WAS SERVICE
BEFORE SELF. AND OF COURSE IS A
MEMBER OF ROTARY. WHY WOULD
DODD BE AT HOME IN THE CAR
MICHAEL ROTARY CLUB. WELL
BECAUSE THE CARMICHAEL ROTARY
CLUB HAD THE SAME SORT OF VALUE
SERVICE ABOVE SELF. SO IT'S
INTERESTING TO ME THAT WHEN YOU
LOOK AT SOMEONE'S CAREER ACROSS
A SPAN OF THEIR LIVES YOU CAN
LOOK AT DOG US AIRFORCE.
SERVING HIS NATION A KIND OF
THIS EARLY MORNING PICKET LOOK
INTO PROBLEMS THAT MIGHT BE
ADDRESSED. FOUND HIS WAY INTO
PUBLIC SERVICE THE CAPITAL
STILL IN GATES AND I WOULD SAY
SERVICE BEFORE SELF. SERVICE
ABOVE SELF FOUND A HOME IN THE
IN THE CARMICHAEL ROTARY CLUB
LIVING OUT THOSE SAME VALUES.
SO I JUST SORT OF SEE A LONG
PERSISTENCE TO THE SAME
DIRECTION ACROSS THE LIFE OF
DOUG CALLAN NOT BROUGHT HIM TO
THIS INSTITUTION TO OUR HOUSE
WHERE SIR FOR SO LONG. A DOG IS
SURVIVED BY HIS BELOVED WIFE
JANE WHO'S WITH US THIS MORNING
HIS SON'S TROIAN LORDS HIS STEP
CHILDREN ACTUALLY ABERCROMBIE
EMPLOYEES WHO DAHLE AND DAVID
STRASBOURG- HIS MOTHER EVERLY
BOSS AND JOIN US HERE. HIS
SISTER CAROLINE SOLOMON AND
MANY GRANDCHILDREN. DOUG
CERTAIN AN INDELIBLE MARK ON
THIS INSTITUTION. AND ON ALL
WHO KNEW HIM. AND I RESPECT
REQUEST WE ADJOURN IN A MEMBER
ABOUT HELEN TODAY THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. THANK YOU MISTER
COOLEY AND MISTER GALLAGHER YOU
TWO ARE RECOGNIZED ON THE
STREET GERMAIN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS AND
THAT IT IS MY HONOR. THIS
MORNING SORRY THIS AFTERNOON TO
ADJOURN IN MEMORY OF. DOUGLAS
HOLLAND ON ON BEHALF OF THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS. I'M IN AS
MANY OF YOU KNOW DOUG WAS A
VITAL PART. OF OUR POLICY
CAUCUS FOR MANY YEARS. YOU KNOW.
IT IS SAID THAT THE CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN ASSEMBLY- ONE OF OUR
GRASSROOTS GROUPS IS THE
CONSCIENCE OF THE REPUBLICAN
PARTY. I THINK THAT WE COULD
SAY VERY. VERY CLEARLY TODAY
THAT DOUG HOLLAND. WAS THE
CONSCIENCE OF THE CALIFORNIA
REPUBLICAN ASSEMBLY CAUCUS.
THERE'S MANY DIFFERENT THINGS
IT COULD BE SAID ABOUT DOUG.
AND MANY OF THE MEN REV
REFERENCED. BY MY COLLEAGUE
FROM RANCHO CORDOVA BUT FARM
BOY. VETERAN TRUSTED ADVISER
AND THAT I THINK IS A BIG ONE
TRUSTED ADVISER FRIEND. GREAT
FRIEND GREAT SENSE OF HUMOR.
SOMEONE WHO ALWAYS HAD.KNOWLEDGE TO BRING TO THE TABLE
BUT HE COULD DO IT IN A WAY
THAT WOULD MAKE YOU LAUGH.
GRANDFATHER BELOVED GRANDFATHER
AND UNCLE. MANY DIFFERENT
THINGS THAT WERE PART OF WHO
DUG WAS. BUT I THINK THAT. WHAT
WAS GREAT ABOUT DOUG IS THAT HE
CAME TO CALIFORNIA. IN HIS
TWENTIES AND STARTED OUT YOU AS
A AS A SMALL BUSINESS OWNER
ACTUALLY RUNNING A SECURITY
SERVICE. BUT HE DECIDED. THAT
HIS REAL PASSION WAS FOR PUBLIC
SERVICE. AND SO YOU KNOW IN IN
THOSE MID TWENTIES HE MADE THE
CAREER DECISION. TO BECOME PART
OF THE REPUBLICAN CAUCUS HERE
TO COME AND WORK IN THE
LEGISLATURE ON BEHALF OF THE
ISSUES THAT HE CARED ABOUT SO
MUCH THEN HE SPENT THE NEXT
TWENTY SEVEN YEARS HERE IN THE
LEGISLATURE DOING JUST THAT.
AND MAKING SO MANY DIFFERENT
GAINES. I LOOK BACK. AND
THERE'S SO MANY DIFFERENT WAYS
THAT HE IMPACTED POLICY FROM
FORESTRY ISSUES TO WATER ISSUES
HE WAS A KEY PLAYER IN THE
WATER BOND DISCUSSIONS AND
NEGOTIATIONS IN TWO THOUSAND
AND NINE TO. DUSTIN'S LAW YOU
KNOW WHICH WAS NAMED AFTER HIS
GRANDSON WHO WAS MURDERED. AND
DOUG TOOK THAT PAINFUL
EXPERIENCE AND TURNED IT INTO
PUBLIC POLICY. THAT HELPS KEEP
CHILDREN SAFE AND THE STATE.
THE OTHER THING I THINK ABOUT
WHEN I THINK ABOUT CALLING HIS
MENTOR. AND DOUG ALWAYS HAD
TIME. FOR OTHER PEOPLE I ALWAYS
HAD TIME TO GIVE OF HIS
KNOWLEDGE TO. YOUNGER
GENERATIONS- TO OTHER PEOPLE
THAT WERE WORKING WITH HIM IN
THE POLICY CAUCUS AND IF YOU IF
YOU TALK AROUND. THE STAFF OF
OUR CAUCUS SO MANY PEOPLE WILL
TELL YOU THAT THEY WERE
MENTORED IN SOME WAY. BY DOUG
COLLINS. NOW I THINK ABOUT MY
OWN LIFE- IT'S REALLY KIND OF
FUNNY HOW DOUG POPPED UP IN MY
LIFE. I FEEL LIKE IN IN
CRITICAL JUNCTURES I REMEMBER
AS A- AS A HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT
AS THE FUTURE FARMERS OF
AMERICA MEMBER YOU KNOW WE'VE
SEEN THESE- YOUNG MEN AND WOMEN
COMING INTO OUR CAPITAL WITH
THE BLUE JACKETS I WAS ONE OF
THOSE AND I REMEMBER VISITING
THE CAPITAL AND WE GOT TO SIT
DOWN WITH DOUG COLLINS. LEE
WHEN HE WAS THE CHIEF OF STAFF
AND I STILL THINK BACK TO A
STORY THAT HE TOLD WHERE HE WAS
TALKING ABOUT. IT WAS KIND OF
MY FIRST LESSON IN MESSAGING.
WHERE DOUG SAID YOU KNOW. A LOT
OF TIMES AGRICULTURAL GROUPS
COE IN AND THEY TALK ABOUT
THEIR PRODUCTS AND THEY TALK
ABOUT. OTHER CROPS AND THAT'S
GOOD BUT YOU NEED TO FIND A WAY
TO BRING IT HOME. TO EVERYDAY
FOLKS INTO THE BROADER PUBLIC
AND SO HE USES AN EXAMPLE- FOR
EXAMPLE IN THE MILK PRICES AND
MILK. POLICY GOES IT'S NOT JUST
HOW IT AFFECTS THE DAIRY FARM
BUT TALK ABOUT HOW IT AFFECTS-
MOMS YOU KNOW YOU ARE BUYING
MILK FOR THEIR CHILDREN- AND
MAKE IT A BROADER. HELP MAKE IT
MORE APPLIED TO A BROADER
STATEMENT HE WAS RIGHT. BECAUSE
SO MUCH OF WHAT WE DO AND FOOD
POLICY IT DOESN'T JUST AFFECT
FARMERS THAT AFFECTS ALL OF US.
BECAUSE WE ALL NEED FOOD D. N.
I REMEMBER A LITTLE BIT LATER
IN TIME WHEN I WAS A AN
ASSEMBLY FELLOW. AND SERVED IN
THE ASSEMBLY FELLOWSHIP PROGRAM
IN THIS BODY. AND DOUG POPPED
UP ONCE AGAIN YOU KNOW AS AS A
KEY CONSULTANT- ON NATURAL
RESOURCES. AND MY MENTOR AT THE
TIME WAS CINDY HILLARY WHO NOW
RUNS OUR BUDGET- POLICY- AND
DOUG WAS THE KEY CONSULTANT
WORKING ON FORESTRY IN A- HELLO
REALLY ALLOW MARK FORESTRY AND
FIRE PROTECTION- LEGISLATION
FIRST OF ITS KIND THAT ALLOWED
US TO. TO THIN MORE TREES AND
HAVE BETTER MANAGEMENT
PRACTICES IN THE FORCE DOUG-
WAS KEY TO THAT NIGHT AND I AND
I CAN RECALL DOUG BEING IN THE
OFFICE. SO MANY DIFFERENT TIMES
WITH THE HUMOR WITH THAT WITH.
BUT ALWAYS YOU KNOW. IT WAS
SAID IN A BIO ABOUT HIM THAT
DOUG ALWAYS STROVE TO EDUCATE
IN A RESPECTFUL AND POSITIVE
WAY AND I THINK THAT'S SO TRUE.
IN A CONVERSATION WITH DOUG
MOST OFTEN LEFT ONE MORE
KNOWLEDGEABLE. THAN BEFORE IT
BEGAN. BUT IN THAT PROCESS I
TELL YOU WHAT HE WOULD BE YOU
WOULD BE LAUGHING- BECAUSE HE
HAD JUST AN AMAZING SENSE OF
HUMOR AND A WAY TO CONNECT- AND
THAT WAS PART OF HIS MENTOR
SHIP I THINK HE BROUGHT PEOPLE
IN. HE ATTRACT THE ATTRACTED
PEOPLE TO HIMSELF BUT HE ALWAYS
PASSED ON. A KNOWLEDGE AND THAT
WAS SUCH A KEY PART. A FEW DOUG
WAS. HE WAS DEVOTED TO HIS
MOTHER. WHO WAS A BIG- FIGURE
IN HIS LIFE ANY ALWAYS
AFFECTIONATELY REFERRED TO EACH
OF HIS SONS EVEN AFTER THEY
WERE GROWN MEN. AS SWEETHEART.
DOUG WAS A PRINCIPLED MAN WHO
BELIEVE THERE IS NOTHING MORE
IMPORTANT THAN PROTECTING. THE
ONES THAT YOU LOVE. AND I GOT
TO SEE. THAT AND DUG ANOTHER
MOMENT THE TO I DON'T EVEN
MAYBE NO HE KNOWS ABOUT AYE AYE
ATTENDED TO. A CHURCH SERVICE
ONE TIME WERE ACTUALLY GOT TO
HEAR DOUG GIVE HIS TESTIMONY-
TO THE CHURCH. AND THE. YOUR
CRIES CHANGE DOES LIFE AND I
GOT TO HEAR A VERY PERSONAL-
TESTIMONY FROM HIM- THAT DAY
AND IT WAS ALWAYS ANOTHER THING
THAT JUST STUCK WITH ME ABOUT
DUG IN AS WE- NOW. WHEN I
BECAME AN ASSEMBLY MEMBER HAD
THE OPPORTUNITY TO WORK WITH
HIM. IN THAT ROLE I CONTINUE TO
RELY ON HIS GOOD ADVICE AND ALL
OF US DO. AND HAVE. IN THE
REPUBLICAN CAUCUS. THE OTHER
THING ABOUT DOUG IS THAT HE MET
HIS TRUE LOVE AND PARTNER IN
JANE. WHO WAS A HUGE PART OF
HIS LOVE WHO IS A HUGE PART OF
HIS LIFE. AND I KNOW THAT SHE
IN THE FAMILY ARE HERE WITH US
TODAY IT WAS A BLESSED IN
LOVING UNION. ONE THAT BROUGHT
DOUG'S. CLOSEST TO HIS FAMILY
AND DUG IN JANE. ENJOYED SO
MANY SO MUCH TIME TOGETHER.
THAT WAS OF HIS FAMILY WAS SO
IMPORTANT TO HIM AND JOIN
TRAVELING TRIPS TO THE COAST
VISITING THE GRAND CHILDREN
DATE NIGHTS BINGE WATCHING
NETFLIX. HOLDING HANDS AND JUST
BEING TOGETHER DOUG WAS A HAPPY
MAN BECAUSE A JANE. AND HIS
FAMILY. AND SO AS I AS I THINK
BACK ABOUT DOUG COLLINS JUST
ALL THE THINGS THAT HE WAS TO
SO MANY PEOPLE THE LIVES HE
TOUCHED THE MENTOR THAT HE WAS.
IT'S A BIG PART OF WHAT THIS
INSTITUTION IS ALL ABOUT IS
ABOUT REALLY NUMBER ONE CARING
ABOUT WHAT HAPPENS OF PEOPLE
CARING ABOUT POLICY. AND HOW IT
AFFECTS CALIFORNIANS ACROSS THE
STATE BUT IT'S ABOUT GIVING
BACK ACQUIRING KNOWLEDGE BUT
GIVING IT BACK TRANSMITTING
KNOWLEDGE. TO THE NEXT
GENERATION. AND DOUG HOLLAND
DID THAT SO VERY WELL. DOUG IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JANE. AND
HIS SONS TROY DOUG JUNIOR.
LAWRENCE AND. ALSO HIS MOTHER
EVELYN BASSIN. AND COUNTLESS
GRAND CHILDREN. NEPHEWS AND
NIECES TO WHOM HE WAS SUCH A
BELOVED FIGURE. MEMBERS I JUST
ASK THAT WE REMEMBER THIS THIS
GREAT LEGACY THAT WE HAD AND
SOMEONE WHO DEVOTED SO MUCH
TIME TO THIS PLACE AND GOOD
PUBLIC POLICY ASKED THAT WE
CLOSE IN MEMORY. OF DOUG
COLLINS. TAKING THIS GALLAGHER
AND MISSED COOLEY. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WALDRON. YOUR RECOGNIZED
FOR YOUR GERMAN MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND MEMBERS.
I SADLY RISE TO ASK THAT WE
ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND FRANK MENDENHALL. WHICH
RAN CATTLEMEN BUSINESS OWNER
COMMUNITY LEADER AND FAMILY MAN.
HE WAS BORN JULY SEVENTH
NINETEEN FIFTY SEVEN AND PASSED
AWAY FROM PANCREATIC CANCER ON
JANUARY TWENTY SEVENTH HE WAS
ONLY SIXTY TWO YEARS OLD. BORN
IN LOVE VALLEY AT THE EASTERN
END OF PALOMAR MOUNTAIN FRANK
WAS PART OF THE HISTORIC
MENDENHALL FAMILY THAT
HOMESTEAD IN THE MOUNTAINS IN
THE EIGHTEEN HUNDREDS. FRANK
MENDENHALL WAS GREAT IN STATURE
BOTH PHYSICALLY AND AS A
RENOWNED CATTLEMEN AND MEMBER
OF THE COMMUNITY. IT WAS FIRST
INTIMIDATING WHEN YOU GOT TO
MEET HIM UNTIL YOU GOT TO KNOW
THE KIND AND CARING PERSON THAT
HE WAS. IN FACT HE TOOK MY SON
UNDER HIS WING AFTER THE LOSS
OF THEIR THIRTY YEAR OLD SON
JOEL AND THAT MEANT A LOT TO
US. FRANK WAS DEEPLY CONNECTED
TO THE LAND BUT ENJOYED
TRAVELING TO EUROPE CANADA AND
THROUGHOUT THE U. S. FRANK WAS
TRULY AND RENAISSANCE MAN. WITH
AN INNOVATIVE MINE THAT COULD
CONQUER PROJECTS RANGING FROM
REPAIRING CARS AND FARM
EQUIPMENT. TO PLUMBING
ELECTRICAL WELDING RUNNING
BARBED WIRE AND FIXING WELLS.
HIS BUSINESS INTERESTS INCLUDED
PURCHASING AND RUNNING THE
SEVENTEEN COTTAGE LAKE HENSCHEL
RESORT AND THE ADJOINING
ROUNDUP BARBECUE GRILL
ESTABLISHMENT THAT EVERYONE
STOP THAT ON THEIR WAY TO AND
FROM THE DESERT. HE HELPED HIS
SON JOLT FOUND ON ORGANIC GRASS
BEEF COMPANY CALLED HOME GROWN
MEETS SELLING TO WHOLE FOODS
MARKETS. AND A POPULAR HUNTING
CLUB TO HELP TRAIN USE HUNTERS
ONE OF THOSE YOUNG HUNTERS WAS
MY SON WHO SHOT HIS FIRST YEAR
TWO YEARS AGO ON THE AND THE
WHOLE PROPERTY. ABOVE ALL FRANK
WAS TO HIS FAMILY. HE WAS
PRECEDED IN DEATH BY HIS
BELOVED SON JOEL HIS AND IS
SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE JANICE.
DAUGHTER IN LAW JENNA
GRANDDAUGHTERS PAISLEY CAN THIS
AND SIERRA AND BROTHER JIM. I
JOIN FRANK'S FAMILY AND FRIENDS
AND CELEBRATING HIS REMARKABLE
LEGACY ACCOMPLISHMENTS AND LOVE
FILLED LIFE AND ASKED WE
ADJOURN IN HIS MEMORY. THANK
YOU MISS WALDRON AND DOCTOR
WEBER YOU ARE RECOGNIZED FOR
YOUR GERMAN THEM. YES MISTER
SPEAKER MEMBERS I RISE ON
BEHALF THE CALIFORNIA
LEGISLATIVE BLACK CAUCUS AND
REQUEST THAT WE JOIN IN MEMORY
OF CATHERINE JOHNSON. JOHNSON
IS BEST KNOWN FOR WORK AS A
MATHEMATICIAN FOR NASA LATER
MEMORIALIZED IN THE MOVIE
HIDDEN FIGURES. ONE IN WHITE
SULPHUR SPRINGS WEST VIRGINIA
IN NINETEEN EIGHTEEN CATHERINE
JOHNSON WAS FIRST KNOWN AS THE
GIRL WHO COUNTS SHE COUNTED
EVERYTHING FROM THE DISHES SHE
WASHED TO THE STEPS SHE WALKED
ON HER WAY TO SCHOOL. AS A
BRILLIANT WITH NUMBERS BECAME
ALL THE MORE APPARENT HER
FAMILY WAS FACED WAS FORCED TO
MAKE CHOICES ALL TOO FAMILIAR
IN SEGREGATED BLACK
COMMUNITIES. HIGH SCHOOL WAS
NOT AVAILABLE TO BLACK STUDENTS
AND WHITE SULPHUR. CATHERINE
AND HER MOTHER JOY LET MOVED TO
INSTITUTE A WEST VIRGINIA TOWN
A HUNDRED AND TWENTY MILES AWAY
THEY DID ACCEPT BLACK STUDENTS
WHILE HER FATHER JOSH WILL STAY
BEHIND TO FARMS SUPPORT THE
FAMILY. CATHERINE JOHNSON CHURN
THROUGH HIGH SCHOOL IN A SINGLE
YEAR AND BEGAN COLLEGE AT THE
AGE OF FOURTEEN. FOUR YEARS
LATER SHE GRADUATED AS A
RESEARCH MATHEMATICIAN. SHE
WENT ON TO TEACH MATH BUT
BEFORE SHE LONG SHE WAS HIRED
AS A QUOTE COMPUTER FOR WHAT
WAS KNOWN UP TO BECOME KNOWN AS
NASA BACK THEN THE COMPUTERS
WERE SKIRT SHE SAID. THERE SHE
CALCULATED THE FIRST PATH
FLIGHT PATH OF AMERICA'S FIRST
MAN IN SPACE IN NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE WHEN JOHN GLENN BECAME THE
FIRST AMERICAN TO ORBIT THE
EARTH IN NINETEEN SIXTY TWO
CAPTAIN JOHNSON WAS JOINED THE
PAIR PARABOLAS AROUND DOING THE
MATH AND ENSURE THAT HE WOULD
GLANCE SAFE. IT WASN'T EASY FOR
BLACK WOMEN I CATHARINE HER
NAME WAS LEFT OFF OF THE REPORT
SHE WROTE THE CALCULATION SHE
COMPUTED WERE CREDITED TO HER
SUPERIORS SHE WAS EVEN EXCLUDED
FROM MEETING. ON HER OWN WORK.
I PRINT SERVICE THE NASA SPAM
THIRTY THREE YEARS TO THE FIRST
MANNED SPACE FLIGHT. MOON
LANDINGS AND THE SPACE SHUTTLE
PROGRAM. BY HER RETIREMENT IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX SHE HAD CO
AUTHOR TWENTY SIX SCIENTIFIC
PAPERS AT THE AGENCY. CATHERINE
JOHNSON HIS LEGACY WILL BE ONE
OF EXCELLENCE AND BRILLIANCE
AND COURAGE. SHE IS SURVIVED BY
HER DAUGHTER JOE LET TO
CATHERINE AND CONSTANCE JOHNSON
CONSTANCE. SHE PASSED AWAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH OF THIS
YEAR AT THE AGE OF ONE HUNDRED
AND ONE. I ASSN COLLEAGUES JOIN
ME IN A JOINING IN MEMORY OF
CATHERINE JOHNSON. THANK YOU
DOCTOR WEBER THANK YOU MEMBERS.
PLEASE BRING THE NAMES OF THE
DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL ALL REQUEST WOULD
JOURNEY MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED
READ AND PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL. ALL OTHER ITEMS
REMAINING WE PASS A RETAIN ALL
MOTION SHALL BE CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING OF FOR THE
BUSINESS I AM READY TO
ENTERTAIN A MOTION TO ADJOURN
MR BONTA MOVES. AND MISS
WALDRON SECONDS THAT THIS HOUSE
STANDS ADJOURNED UNTIL THURSDAY
MARCH FIFTH AT NINE AM WE ARE
RICHER.